Futurama is a cult hit now but the first
time around the second show from the
creator of The Simpsons was never given
a real shot to shine Matt Groening
became a true force in television
animation after creating the Simpsons
which has aired in astonishing 600 plus
episodes on Fox
since premiering 30 years ago in 1989 in
the late 90s with the Simpsons having
become a cultural phenomena Fox began to
express interest in a new show from
graining he came back to Fox with the
show that would eventually become
Futurama shut up and take my money it
should have been a surefire hit instead
though graining says that Fox seemingly
never really wanted Futurama to succeed
and even sabotage their own show rather
than let graining have another hit
during an interview with mother jones
graining had some not-so-great things to
say about working with fox execs in
hollywood you can't believe what babies
people are it's really like being in
junior high school raining even said
that Fox executives weren't fans of The
Simpsons either revealing you can't
expect people to behave in their own
best interest it's in Fox's best
interest for this show to be a success
but they'd rather mess with the show and
have them fail then allow creators
independence and let them succeed they
don't like the Simpsons at Fox so how
did this affect Futurama
the network moved the show around from
time slot to timeslot then let it die a
quiet death in 2003 before it was
eventually revived by Comedy Central a
few years later but the network seemed
to be working against the show even
before it debuted when Futurama was
originally coming down the pike graining
wanted Futurama to air at 8:30 p.m. on
Sundays directly after the Simpsons and
ahead of the x-files in order to give
the show the best chance to find a large
audience this seemed like a no brainer
but Fox disagreed for whatever reason
choosing instead to show only two
episodes of Futurama in the sunday night
lineup before moving the series to a
much less desirable Tuesday night
timeslot by the time the second season
of Futurama came around Fox moved the
show back to the 8:30 p.m. Sunday spot
in which the first two episodes aired
then in a move that alienated audiences
further Fox shifted the show again in
middle of the season this time bumping
it up to 7 o'clock p.m. on Sunday and a
regularly time sporting events which
were a huge moneymaker for Fox made it
even harder to anticipate when Futurama
would air each week this up-and-down
scheduling had another disappointing
consequence Fox held on to episodes of
Futurama made for the third and fourth
seasons and reserved them for a fifth
season that didn't even end up airing on
the network Fox never formally canceled
Futurama not in the way that television
series are usually acts nowadays the
network simply stopped purchasing new
episodes of Futurama and the series went
out of production ahead of the fall 2003
broadcast season at least I still have
my self-respect a couple years later
though Comedy Central picked up Futurama
the series lasted another three seasons
on the network before it ended in 2013
proving graining right and Fox wrong in
a 2003 interview with the Calgary Sun
braining offered his candid thoughts on
the situation the people at Fox didn't
ever support the show and it wasn't to
their taste and in my opinion they're
out of their minds but they don't like
the Simpsons either the idea of a TV
show that they haven't gotten their
greasy fingers all over creatively
drives them nuts that's why almost
everything else is so lousy we won the
Emmy for best animated show and I didn't
even get a begrudging phone call from
anyone at Fox that's a dark company that
they can't even make a fake phone call
ouch tell them how you really feel Matt
bye Michael ah so mad alas ultimately
though graining got the last laugh
Futurama became a cult classic hit on a
different network The Simpsons continues
to run to this day and his show at
Netflix disenchantment scored a second
and third season in late 2018 you know
what they say Living Well is the best
revenge
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you